alex jones oh
he had a court appearance and it was a
disaster his lawyer accidentally sent a
copy of his cell phone contents to the
opposing lawyers and now his phone's
been turned over to the january 6
committee among the materials on alex
jones's phone was a nude picture of his
wife that was allegedly sent to roger
stone
why would he send that to roger stone i
guess he's trying to impress roger stone
at one point the judge had to admonish
him for what appeared to be chewing gum
get your gum out mr jones not gone what
is it i had my tooth pulled uh a week
and a half ago and it's i had some laws
earlier so you're chewing on your gauze
would you like to show you no
oh here's alex jones everyone to answer
some of the questions that we might have
alex the microphone is yours go ahead
infowars.com
infowars.com howard like you just said
we have passed through the depths of
hell infowars has come out stronger than
ever i tell you what because we love god
here because i'm a man who loves god and
loves the truth and i'm not a godless
bloodthirsty evil person who supports
kangaroo courts you don't understand the
fight is not over they are beta testing
what they did to me they will do to
everyone there will be power outages
cyber attacks mass starvation total
collapse the war is not over you need to
support us you need to give us money
we're losing money we need money buy
insta hard right now instagram do you
actually do you take insta hard yourself
to give you a hard deck now look it's
not a thing of oh i can't get a boner or
something like that this is a high
selling product to promote procreation
it's great for your prostate health i
take about eight or nine instagrams a
day which is one of the lighter doses
and you want to have the hardest excuse
my language but reddest direction
possible because it's the right order
the better when you're having sex you're
supposed to come 27 times a day this is
what doctors are saying if you listen to
doctors on your show and what they say
you would understand that you know are
you are you are you chewing are you
chewing gum during my broadcast you know
there's a rule no gum chewing uh during
the broadcast this is another thing that
you talk about these kangaroo the demon
judge oh you're chewing gum you're
chewing gum i'll be honest with you with
you i'll be honest here i did have the
gum under my mouth and she didn't see
because they're [ __ ] stupid i'm sorry
to curse but these judges are pretty
[ __ ] you want to know what i'm going
to do with the next trial too i'm going
to chew potato chips while here i'll
show you what i'm going to do ask me a
question are you aware i'm not chewing
chips you can look around
look at my mouth while i'm not chewing
you damn son of a [ __ ] all right listen
i was reading they turned your phone
over to the january 6 committee and i'm
wondering if you're worried about
anything that might be on there there's
nothing on there there's no dick pics on
there there's nothing listen these
chicken neck perverts go oh i want to
see jones phone i want to see that big
insta-hard dick you ain't gonna find any
dick pics they got all the time in the
world to go through my phone with the
imf and the world banks looking at my
phone once you look at hillary's emails
why don't you look in there stop looking
at this and if they put anything in
there it's planted all right anything
send the picture of your wife to a guy
you know another guy what what was that
all about i did do you want to see it
it's really good here i'll say that
check it out oh he sends it to everyone
hold on wait wait that was a dick pic
don't open that up
all right come on anything else you want
to say because i want to move on i got a
lot of things to cover what do you want
to say listen i got a lot of things to
cover here too you got to buy the insta
hard you got to get the products for the
female info warriors out there you need
the new insta wet supplements half off
through the weekend
at infowars.com these globalists want to
dry you up that's what they want to
strengthen their breeding programs the
insta-wet is going to get you soap and
sock and wet it's filled with rat boys
and a tar
oh calm down baby it's the safest
highest quality women's supplement out
there get insta-wet go to infowars.com
support the war
infowars.com all right thank you for
explaining everything i'm glad to hear
from you